we are here with eric stonestreet and
here with us as well the charcuterie
queen aka karina caffarelli
i am so excited this is such a good
education for me right now i'm so
excited it's gonna be good and eric you
did a rose salami challenge recently
with your fiance yeah mine turned out
terrible hers was actually
like pretty impressive so
teach us not only how to do the roads
but how to be less intimidated by making
your own charcuterie board which is just
such a game changer of a treat for
everybody oh yes
i'm so excited to show you guys so we're
definitely going to start with the rose
first star of the show how do we do so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the first piece of salami just like
this and we're just going to kind of hug
it around the glass then what we're
going to do is we're going to repeat
this all around the glass overlapping
yep overlapping so taking another piece
overlapping just all around the glass
this would be a great room for a bloody
mary yes honestly
i feel like they have like sausages
hanging out of bloody mary's erica they
do i actually just went somewhere where
they've happened this is a family show
perfect so once we have the first like
round of applause
yes we are
okay we're gonna take the second layer
and do the exact same thing so we're
just gonna keep going right over the
glass and you wanna like then go in
where you didn't or follow the exact
same line you can manipulate it so you
can if you want you can go on the
opposite side of the line yeah i feel
like filling in bricks yeah i feel like
covering the seams
are we going for a thread but we're
going we're going for it because you
know what the more pieces you pick the
bigger the rose is going to look on the
board okay so you want it to look really
nice and full alrighty so now this is
the this is the fun step so we're going
to move the plate out of the way
so you want to kind of look at the board
and say all right where are we going to
put this rose and you want to kind of be
the center of attention so we're going
to put it right in the middle so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
it and flip it right over
and you got the person going
see look at that you did it
perfect oh no you gotta look a little
bit perfect
perfect
see
look at that
we just made this yeah isn't it amazing
and now we're working yeah
yeah
yeah you take a little piece and just
now that we've got our centerpiece like
what would you do next help now we're
gonna go to the prosciutto yeah with the
prosciutto sometimes you get pieces of
prosciutto that are a little annoying so
i'm gonna show you i'm going to show you
pieces that you could just plate them
down really nicely so what we're going
to do is just take them because these
are folded perfectly but sometimes you
do get pieces that are a little weird
but what you're going to do just plate
it right around you're doing perfect no
now i'm going on my own now
that's the beauty of it you could do
whatever you want so after this we can
go in with some fruit
and i like to add here what am i doing
listen you are an expert
now what so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the fruit and this
is where i really like to play with
color and add color onto the board and
that's where you're really going to make
the board pop okay what you can do is
take your fruit you're going to take
some oranges some kiwis citrus season is
right now so that's perfect
okay oranges kiwis where okay right in
there
making my board pop so now what we're
going to do is we're going to play with
the cheese a little bit all right so
brie you have it's super creamy this is
like perfect right now to eat
optimal temperature you always want to
eat your cheese and charcuterie board at
room temperature okay so what we're
going to do i'm actually going to plate
that right next to the our salami rose
because i know that the brie and the
salami is really perfect together later
on i love brie i could spread it on me
too so now what we're going to do is
we're going to play with a little bit of
flavor and going with this fig jam
have you ever had fig jam yes i love it
okay have you ever put fig jam with a
little bit of brie and a little bit of
salami
perfect all right you guys any charcoal
charcuterie board yeah you got it look
at that you have it hugging right there
so when you have people going in later
on that's better no but that's perfect
you have it right there with debris and
the fig jam so it's easy for people to
go in and get that really perfect bite
so after that we're going to take some
crackers i love these crackers they have
a little they're the rainbow
yeah
crackers
and they go perfect with the prosciutto
the brie
tommy and i love the dates
yeah do you like that i love dates me
too yup i'm telling you with them
so we did the dates next okay perfect
and then what we can do always the last
step what i like to do is go in
well before that we always had to go
with a little bit of garnish so what i
like to do is i like to kind of keep it
near the salami to make it look like
it's a little stem coming out of the
salami so what i like to do is just
plate the rosemary just like that
and you can even put it right in the
front like so
let's see i love that that looks perfect
thank you
hey you know what mine doesn't suck no
absolutely not they look beautiful look
at that
it looks perfect
yeah mine's pretty nutty
i'm actually like i'm i love it i gotta
tell ya i feel really good like they
look beautiful i'm not an overconfident
person
no you should be especially after i feel
good about this absolutely and it's on a
lazy susan so you could spin it around
for your guests to enjoy
eric oh eric
that looks amazing oh
that looks see got all the colors i love
adding the oranges it looks beautiful
you know what i see when i see yours
what bountiful
thank you that's what a lot of people
call me absolutely
[Music]
you